[Music]
and now more live coverage from Chicago
up next
Amy Goodman and Adam Cohen
okay and welcome to the 32nd annual
Chicago Tribune printers roll it Fest my
name is Thomas Collis and I'd like to
give a special thank you to all of the
festival sponsors the theme for this
year's festival is what's your story the
festival encourages all of you to share
everything all the stories you hear this
weekend on Twitter Instagram or Facebook
with the hashtag PRL f/16 you can keep
the spirit of the lit fest going
year-round by downloading the printers
ro app where you'll find all the chicago
tribune premium book contents free and
discounted ebooks for subscribers and
the complete the completes printers roll
it fest schedule if you download today
you get a free ebook and five dollars
off lit fest merchandise today's program
is being broadcast live on c-span to's
book TV if there's time at the end for a
Q&A session then we'll have you line up
at the microphone here to your right so
that the home viewing audience can hear
your questions before we begin please
turn off or silence all of your phones
turn off the flash on any cameras with
that I would like to welcome the author
of Democracy Now Amy Goodman
along with the author of imbeciles the
Supreme Court American eugenics and the
sterilization of carry buck Adam comb
[Applause]
thank you very much Thomas first I'd
like to begin by congratulating Amy it's
your 20th anniversary of democracy now
that's a great milestone and we all
appreciate very much what you do I
wanted to jump in by talking about
something in the introduction to your
book um you tell a story about in 1999
you were all going to Seattle for the
WTO meeting and your co-host Juan
Gonzalez who was also a columnist for
The Daily News was coming along and he
mentioned to his editors at the Daily
News that he was going and their
reaction was the WTO what is that and
they didn't get it you all go and of
course that was a huge huge
international news story over 600 people
arrested major protests tear gas and all
that and suddenly the Daily News wants
stories from him from the WTO and in the
in the story you get it the fact that
the story you're telling is not just
about politics in this book it's a lot
of it is media criticism and here's a
story about the mainstream media being
clueless not understanding the
importance of the WTO you also have
other stories about them being biased
and just getting things wrong so just to
start things off I wonder if you talked
a little bit about your competitors or
colleagues in the mainstream media and
how do you think they're doing these
days well well first of all I'm really
glad at them that you raised one because
we've been doing democracy now together
for all of its 20 years we began in 1996
is the only daily election show in
public broadcasting we're basically
planning to do this for nine months the
election happened and then we'd fold up
the operation move on to another project
but there was more demand for it after
the election than before that was the
election of oh it was President Clinton
versus Bob Dole versus Ross Perot
and I think the reason is because that
hunger for independent voices we were
using the primary system as a way to go
from state to state to find out what
people were doing on the ground and
that's really what counts I mean in fact
then most people weren't voting I didn't
it was apathy how were they involved was
it that they didn't think there was a
difference between the candidates
was it the obstacles that are put in the
way to people voting and those have only
increased now over this 20 years so
after the election we continued and then
the show just really blossomed first as
a radio show and then the week of
September 11 2001 we went on our first
television show in New York and it TV
stations around the country started to
ask if they could run Democracy Now here
in Chicago I think it's live every
morning on can on Chicago Action Network
and on radio stations here and around
the country now on 1,400 stations and I
think the reason it really goes to what
you are talking about Adam I mean being
there on the front lines when the
corporate media doesn't even know a
story is about to happen it's not that
we're profits that we've got some
crystal ball that we can see what others
don't see it's that we're listening and
we're there and we're on the ground the
Battle of Seattle did not come out of
nowhere people in many different
organizations and communities had been
organizing and we're covering these
communities I mean you had high school
kids you had environmentalists you had
union leaders you had doctors nurses you
had international people from around the
world farmers from France who are all
saying what is this supranational
organization the World Trade
Organization that can overturn the laws
of democratically elected legislatures
around not only our country but around
the world just say it's WTO illegal like
for example tobacco we have those signs
and say you know on the Sun every single
cigarette pack you know this causes
cancer we accept this in other countries
if they were to put on that sign they
could be told you are introducing a
barrier to trade that is WTO illegal but
people have been organizing for a long
time when one
his will then bosses at the Daily News
now he's just retired after 29 years
there they said you know what's the WTO
and so his other DN democracy now
brought him to Seattle and I have to say
when I was saying okay well we've got to
go out and do this he said wait I got to
finish my piece for the Daily News they
said hey wait a second here you're here
and one totally recognized he was there
because of this scrappy grassroots
global an embedded independent
international investigative news hour
and the respect I also have for one when
he retired a few weeks ago I was giving
a speech we're on this hundred city tour
this is around city 80 now I was giving
a speech somewhere and as I was quoting
one I was getting pictures sent to me
from the Frances Tavern in downtown
Manhattan where the Daily News was
having a retirement party I mean there
he was with Governor Cuomo then there he
was with mayor de Blasio of course never
the twain shall meet they'd worked out
in advance how each one could under one
and then leave before the other one came
in and supposedly they're both Democrats
but then you also have Geraldo Rivera
you had Senator Schumer and I was saying
you know I'm giving speech I said wait
is that the governor is that the senator
I think half of them were there to
insure to make sure with their own eyes
that this guy who had been dogging him
for so long was actually retiring but
just a few words of what one had to say
a few months ago when he was the first
Latino journalist inducted into the New
York journalism Hall of Fame and you
know we democracy now packed sardis
there receive ES and there is the New
York Times but we had two tables and we
were so excited when he stood up and his
words I think also very much expressed
the mission of democracy now going to
where the silences and the theme of
printers row of this literary festival
people telling their stories he said I
figured my
contribution would be not writing about
outcasts neighborhoods but from them not
simply to entertain but to change not
after the fact but before it when
coverage could still make a difference
he said I've tried to use as many of my
columns as possible to probe the
injustice 'as visited upon the powerless
yes the rich and famous are also victims
on occasion but they have so many
politicians lobbyists lawyers gossip
columnist and even editorial writers
ready to jump to their defense that
they'll always do fine without my help
he said I prefer the desperate unknown
reader who comes to me because he or she
has gone everywhere else and no one will
listen more often than not I come across
unexpected gems human beings whose
tragedies illuminate the landscape and
whose courage hopefully inspires the
reader to believe that there is indeed
some greater good served by a free press
than just chronicling or influencing the
ouster of one group of politicians by
another yes one has left the Daily News
but he is staying with his democracy now
[Applause]
that was wonderful
on March 20th you had a rather
high-profile moment of as a media critic
some of you may have seen this you were
on CNN on brian Stelter show and you
were talking about what you saw as the
problems with the coverage of the
presidential election and you had a very
salient example just a couple days
earlier had been Super Tuesday and on
that night is the election returns came
in as you pointed out on CNN MSNBC CNN
Fox did not cover Bernie Sanders remarks
on election night instead while he was
speaking there was an empty podium at
Donald Trump's headquarters and they
actually had their cameras on the empty
podium waiting for Donald Trump
you saw this as maybe not the finest
hour in American television journalism
do you want to talk about how you
believe the media has been covering this
campaign well you know it was not only
being on CNN but a little bit after that
we were racing to the San Francisco
Airport and I got this call can you come
over to aj+ and do a quick interview aj+
is the digital version of Al Jazeera you
know
your America sadly closed I hope
al-jazeera doesn't follow suit but I
mean we didn't have much time at all as
we race to these hundred cities but I
said you know are you on the way to the
airport because we're in the car to the
airport they said yes I say okay three
minutes they said yeah three minutes
it's really three minutes I'm running in
and I'm running out fine so I go in and
I really said the same thing on aj+ as I
did on CNN within days there were more
than ten million views of this now I
think it's up to thirteen point seven or
fourteen million views it was three
minutes you know everyone said well it
pays in life to take a detour but but I
wasn't saying anything different than I
think most of you would have said it's
just that these views don't hit the
corporate media radar and yet I think
they represent the majority of people in
this country I really I really do
believe that those were concerned about
war and peace
those are concerned about the growing
inequality in this country those who are
concerned about climate change the feed
of the planet are not a fringe minority
not even a silent majority but the
silenced majority silenced by the
corporate media which is why we have to
take it back so being
being on brian Stelter show and brian
used to be at the new york times as adam
was and he was a media critic there and
he has a very interesting show on CNN
called reliable sources on Sunday
morning where he looks at the media and
but you know I can't tell the difference
I couldn't single out CNN because I
can't tell the difference between CNN
MSNBC and Fox these days and that goes
to your question about March 15 they
called it Super Tuesday 3 that was the
five primaries of I think was North
Carolina Ohio Florida Missouri in
Illinois so that was when Marco Rubio
remember Senator Marco Rubio he pulled
out because he didn't win his home state
of Florida and he gave a speech and they
all ran it as they should that was when
Governor John Kasich won his first
primary his home state of Ohio remember
Governor Kasich and he gave his speech
as they should they covered it Ted Cruz
they gave his speech he gave his speech
Hillary Clinton she spoke gave her
speech after North Carolina Ohio and
Florida and she was right to go then
three solid wins but it was
neck-and-neck in Illinois her home state
and Missouri and so she was smart to
give it before you know the outcome of
those and she gave her speech and they
ran it and then it as Adam said they
show this all of them this empty podium
at one of Donald Trump's Florida
mansions and the pundits are just
filling the airtime you know the pundits
you got on all the networks these
pundits who know so little about so much
explaining the world to us and getting
it so wrong and they fill the air time
until Trump speaks for half an hour and
they play the whole speech and that
pretty much wrapped it up right I mean
that's everyone that's Clinton Cruz and
Kasich and Rubio and Trump oh my gosh
Bernie who Bernie Sanders where was he
I mean they did say neck and neck in
Missouri and Illinois but where was the
pundits on television weren't even
speculating they weren't saying I mean
did he fall asleep did he take the night
off
nothing
and we weren't planning to do this but
because of the vacuum in the corporate
media we decided that we would the next
day in the morning on democracy I'll
play an excerpt of Bernie Sanders speech
I mean where was he by the way he was in
Phoenix we just did a swing through
Tucson Flagstaff and Phoenix so I know
this for a fact I met many many people
who were at this speech in Phoenix were
thousands and thousands and thousands
and thousands of thousands it was by far
the biggest speech that night he was in
Phoenix giving a major address so the
next day we decided to run an excerpt of
that speech who would have thought it
would be a revolutionary act to play an
excerpt of a speech of a major party
candidate on a major primary night or
the morning after but that's what it has
become that is not acceptable you know
what Noam Chomsky says about
manufacturing consent have the media
manufacturers consent for example for
war well they also do it for candidates
and around elections and that has to be
challenged I mean it wasn't about
whether you were for or against Bernie
Sanders he's broken so many records I
mean in March 44 million dollars he
raised to Hillary Clinton's 29 million I
think is more than 7 million donors
average like $27 Hillary Clinton I mean
we were in Laurel Canyon so is she we
weren't in the same place she was behind
closed doors at a fundraiser at George
and Amal Clooney house right and I think
the going rate for a seat at the head
table was like 350 thousand dollars I
mean that was for a couple but and on
Clooney was on television George Clooney
he was asked about it and even he said
it was obscene and he was throwing the
party but in this issue and this is
another issue that is hardly raised in
the networks it's not just Hillary
Clinton where is all of the money these
candidates are raising going to well the
vast majority goes to the network's
right it goes to the network's because
the candidates are paying for TV
advertising so these networks are hardly
going to
over in an routine day-to-day way I'm
not saying there isn't an occasional
special on money in politics they are
hardly going to cover this critical
issue a few weeks ago when 1200 people
were arrested in Washington DC with
democracy Awakening and democracy spring
you know challenging the corrupting
influence of money in politics where
were the networks I mean as they were
getting arrested they were shouting
whereas I'm SMB city were CNN this is
1200 people getting arrested and these
issues are what fuel movements Bernie
Sanders did not create a movement this
year he rode a movement that we saw for
example coming out of occupy in 2011
people across the political spectrum
saying no to the corrupting influence of
money and politics but also deeply
concerned about the growing inequality
in this country so Amy you took a stand
a little walk down memory lane when you
mentioned Kasich and Rubio and you could
have mentioned that there are a few more
Jeb Bush and Carly Fiorina and Martin
O'Malley
they all said get nostalgic for the
whole thing but um but they're gone now
and and we seem to be drifting very
rapidly towards a Clinton Trump general
election which is somewhat remarkable in
many ways um I wonder if you could talk
a little bit about how you think we got
here and where do you think we're headed
both in November and then what does this
say about where we're headed as a nation
and I hope you're gonna chime in here
too this is a two-way conversation and
I'm really looking forward to talking
about your book imbeciles which we're
going to do after this answer but one
thing that is absolutely critical to
talk about is you know Donald Trump's
racism and what this means and I want to
talk about the terror and let me put
those together for you you know I come
originally out of Pacifica Radio five
stations started in 1949 by a war
resistor who came into the detention
camps in California and said we got to
start a media network that's not run by
Corp
to profit from war but run by
journalists and artists and that's how
Pacific was born KPFA the first station
in 49 KPFK and 59 Bai my station New
York in 60 KPFT in Houston and 70 and
WPF W in Washington 77 but this is what
I want to relate to what's happening
today KPFT in Houston goes on the air in
1970 within a few weeks it's blown off
the air by the Ku Klux Klan they
strapped dynamite to the base of
transmitter only radio station in the
country to be blown up few weeks later
they get back on their feet they rebuild
the transmitter they go back on the air
and the Klan straps 15 times the
dynamite to the base of the transmitter
blows it up again the first time they
blow it up by the way it was in the
middle of Arlo Guthrie singing Alice's
Restaurant and I thought that was a good
song but finally they go back in the air
in January of 1971 then PBS is there in
its infancy to broadcast the moment Arlo
Guthrie comes back into Houston to
finish a song live on the air and I
can't remember if it was the Grand
Dragon or the exalted Cyclops because I
often confuse their titles but he said
he said it was just proudest act and I
think that's because he understood how
dangerous independent media is dangerous
because it allows people to speak for
themselves
and when you hear someone speaking from
their own experience whether it's a
Palestinian child or an Israeli
grandmother an aunt an Iraq or an uncle
in Afghanistan it challenges it breaks
down the caricatures and stereotypes
that fuel the hate groups it's not that
you agree with what you hear I mean how
often do we agree with our family
members even you know you say it sounds
like my Bobo my baby my mother or my
aunt but you begin to understand where
someone is coming from that
understanding is the beginning of peace
I think the media can be the greatest
force for peace on earth
instead all too often it's been wielded
as a weapon of war now I just told you
the story that happened 47 years ago in
1970 a story about history and the Ku
Klux Klan I cannot believe we're talking
about the Ku Klux Klan today
in the 2016 presidential race how is it
possible that the presumptive nominee of
a major political party Donald Trump
right the Republican presumptive nominee
when asked by Jake Tapper on CNN if he
would disavow support of a major white
supremacist a major Klan leader David
Duke I can't remember if he was exalted
Cyclops or Grand Dragon but if he would
disavow support of an avowed Klan leader
and the Ku Klux Klan Donald Trump said
he would he waffled he would have to
look more deeply into this when was the
last time you heard Donald Trump say he
had to look more deeply into anything
before he spoke but this time he had to
weigh this and what was it that he had
to weigh you know which Klan chapter was
it he wouldn't want to generalize to all
the Kukla Ku Klux Klan chapters in the
United States this is terrifying and you
put it together with the violence at his
rallies now no presidential candidate
especially if you have major rallies of
thousands of people as responsible for
everything that happens at a rally but
you can set the tone you can say no to
all violence instead you have this
presidential candidates saying he'll pay
the legal fees of his supporters who are
arrested you know like the supporter who
sucker-punched a black lives matter
activist and then afterwards said next
time he would kill him I mean the only
saving grace here is you might have seen
the USA Today report The Times reports
now I was watching Steve Brill the legal
publisher who was saying what when he
heard that the only silver lining was
well you know that was the first time he
heard that old Trump was going to pay
his legal fees on his own that he
doesn't often pay his own legal fees but
this is extremely serious because we
need to talk about not just Ku Klux Klan
as a kind of well we even young people I
mean here we're at a school have heard
of the KKK but we have to talk about the
terror campaign you know the Ku Klux
Klan was a home
terrorist organization and it terrorized
killed maimed thousands of mainly
African Americans in this country and
this is a story that must be retold
especially now so that it is not
repeated now Adam your thoughts on the
election and then we're talking about
and then we're talking about imbeciles
not to make any connection between
moving right into that um there's
obviously so much to say but I think you
you touched on a very important thing
you talked about know'm Chomsky and his
idea about the media manufacturing
consent
another thing that media theorists talk
about is this fear of legitimate debate
they talk about how when you look at the
media in any given nation in any given
period of time there's a sphere of
debate that that the media that society
has decided is legitimate and then other
spheres that are not and that's where
all the discussion goes on so those the
talking heads you talked about who know
so little about so much they're all
operating in that sphere what's
frightening to me about the current
presidential election among other things
is that that sphere is changing if you
look at what we're debating now suddenly
the discussion is well should a
mexican-american who was born in Indiana
and whose family has been here for quite
a while is he a legitimate judge well
that didn't used to be part of the
discussion and that is a discussion now
and we're hearing both sides but there
aren't two sides on this so to me that's
what's scary and then it's the same
thing with well should should someone
accept the endorsement of a Ku Klux Klan
leader as you say we're not sure exactly
what form of leader well that didn't
used to be part of the debate and now it
is so to me that's what's frightening
and you have to worry what will happen
in 2020 where is the debate going
because things we all agreed you could
not talk about because they were morally
so reprehensible like the idea that a
federal judge who happens to be of
Mexican American heritage is a little
mad judge that that's part of the debate
now you have to worry where the
country's headed you know I remember 10
years ago hearing the debates in the
corporate media whether we should engage
in torture I felt the same
way we're actually having debates about
this but you mentioned the judge and
that is going to allow us to segue into
imbeciles because well this is the story
astonishing story and those of you who
are regular viewers and listeners of
democracy now I probably saw Adam Cohen
on Democracy Now talking about this
amazing book imbeciles the Supreme Court
American eugenics and the sterilization
of Carrie buck before you tell us about
how the story relates to today because
this goes back to 1927 this is a
literary festival that's talking about
telling stories and I always think that
is the place to begin tell us the story
of this young woman Carrie buck and how
her story came to make history in this
country sure so Carrie buck was a poor
white woman from Charlottesville
Virginia being raised in part on the
streets by her single mother and she's
taken in by a foster family this is in
the early 1900s the foster family is
quite mean to her makes her do the
housework makes her do housework for the
neighbors takes her out of school
although she was doing quite well in
school after the fifth grade and then
one summer she's raped by a relative of
the foster family when she becomes
pregnant rather than try to help her
they decide to have her declared
epileptic and feeble-minded she wasn't
epileptic
she wasn't feeble-minded but it was not
hard to do at that time and she gets
sent off to this Dickensian institution
in Virginia called the Virginia Colony
for epileptics and feeble-minded she
arrives there sadly for her right after
Virginia has passed this terrible
eugenic sterilization law and it's hard
to imagine now and it we don't really
learn much about in school but a
majority of states in the 20th century
passed eugenic sterilization laws that
were based on the idea that there were
certain people who were bringing our
gene pool down and we're having the
wrong kind of children and they had to
be stopped
so this authorized states to forcibly
sterilized all kinds of people the
eugenics the feeble-minded which only
met people who did badly on IQ exams
which were terrible at the time and that
was Kerry bucks problem she answered
some questions wrong when she
- wrong by their standards when she got
to the colony but also the disabled
people the the poor the indolent as they
called them all these categories were
enough to get you declared to be
unworthy of reproducing and have the
state actually sterilize you and this
was a big deal seventy thousand people
were sterilized um so Kari buck is
chosen to be the first person in
Virginia sterilized under the new law
and also to be at the center of a test
case because Virginia wanted to have the
law upheld by the courts before they
started doing it so this case makes its
way up to the US Supreme Court Carrie
buck is railroaded she's given a lawyer
by the colony who actually was the
former chairman of the board of the
colony he believed in sterilization and
he seemed to want his own client to be
sterilized this goes up to the US
Supreme Court and what's really shocking
is I think it's not hard to imagine that
there were places in the 1920s that had
sterilization that were bad doctors like
the doctor who wanted to sterilize
Carrie but but this got up to the US
Supreme Court and the US Supreme Court
at that time the Chief Justice was
William Howard Taft former President of
the United States the man who wrote this
opinion was Oliver Wendell Holmes
thought by many to be the greatest
justice in American history Louis
Brandeis signed on to the eight-to-one
majority so what happened is when this
case got to the place that we count on
in our society to look out for the weak
for the poor to make sure the justice is
served
eight to one they not only upheld the
Virginia law said the Kerry bucks should
be sterilized
but they also said to the nation we need
more eugenic sterilization go out and do
more and that's in the opinion as well
so this was really a low point in
American law and a terrible story as you
say about one woman who ends up being
sterilized and living out the rest of
her life without children and the famous
quote of Oliver Wendell Holmes yes in
the opinion he writes three generations
of imbeciles are enough this is from the
US Supreme Court and in hence the title
and carry buck as I mentioned that was
not an imbecile at all she was doing
well in school her mother who was also
the colony not an imbecile was taken in
because you know she wasn't leading the
kind of life that the middle-class
social workers wanted her to lead and
Kerry did have a child as a result of
the rape a child who
sadly died in infancy but that child
wasn't there was nothing wrong with that
child either but they introduced
evidence at trial saying that she
somehow didn't respond rapidly enough to
cues that the expert witness gave her so
that they that he could tell that she
was an imbecile as well so just a
terrible decision yes that's a terrible
phrase and really a low point for
American law so talk about what happens
to Carrie buck next yeah so Carrie buck
is sterilized again forcibly against her
will and then lives out the rest of her
life she marries she marries again she
had always wanted to have children she's
unable to later in life people who know
her say she absolutely wasn't
feeble-minded in a retirement home where
she lived she still loved to do the
crossword puzzle and read the newspaper
every day and then her sister Doris was
also one of the first people in Virginia
to be sterilized Doris is sterilized at
a very young age and then late in her
life
Doris writes to the colony for
epileptics and feeble-minded to find out
how old she is because she didn't know
and she wanted to know if she qualified
for Social Security and the leader of
the colony at that time who was a much
better person than the leader of 1920s
went to visit her and told her how old
she was she was eligible for Social
Security and also told her for the first
time that she had been sterilized and
Doris Buck and her husband begin crying
because their whole lives they've been
trying to have children and that the
doctor kept telling them it was their
fault and only in old age were they told
no the state of Virginia decided that
you were unworthy of reproducing so both
Carrie and her sister had these very sad
lives done for horrible ideological
reasons and you mentioned that this led
to the sterilization of some 70,000
people now related to the issue of
immigration and eugenics yeah so the
eugenics movement which started in
England and came over to America the
genesis believed that it was critical to
uplift the human race in general and our
national gene pool in particular they
saw these groups that I mentioned the
disabled and the poor of the idle and so
forth as bringing our gene
and they had two solutions one was to
try to fix the people who were here to
sterilize the ones who weren't
reproducing and get the others who were
worthy to reproduce more but the other
thing is they wanted to protect us from
the threat of bad genes entering the
country and the eugenics movement which
was very powerful in the 1920s was in
large part responsible for the
Immigration Act of 1924 which
dramatically changed American
immigration and what it did is a cut off
immigration from the countries where the
eugenicist believed people with bad
genes lives so Eastern Europe a lot of
Eastern European Jews they were worried
were coming to the country Italy they
thought that Italians were inferior and
it opened the doors to Northern
Europeans who they thought had better
genes so that became the law of the land
and after 1924 the complexion in
literally every way of immigrants who
came into America changed dramatically
and one sobering thought I had as I was
working on this is in recent years it's
come to light that that otto frank was
writing repeatedly to the state
department in the 1940s trying to get
visas for himself and his wife and his
two daughters Margot and Anne and he was
turned down repeatedly because of the
immigration law of 1924 so Anne Frank
ends up dying in a concentration camp
and it was very chilling to realize that
she had been put in that concentration
camp and died because the Nazis believed
that Jews and people like Ann Frank were
inferior but she also was put there in
large part because the US Congress
believed that and wouldn't let her and
her family in when they were trying to
come in so the genetics movement was
very powerful and did a lot of damage to
our country Margaret Sanger yeah
Margaret Sanger you know there were a
lot of progressives who were eugenicist
this is something that progressives you
know need to think about mark Margaret
Sanger Louis Brandeis who was known as
the people's lawyer he was the great
progressive on the Supreme Court
he signed onto it Harvard University the
president of Harvard University the
president Merritt Meredith major
eugenicist the first president of
Stanford this was a movement largely of
intellectuals of progressives who
believed in science believed in progress
but somehow really got on
terribly wrong track and you're talking
about an eight to one decision of the US
Supreme Court this was not closed not
closed and the only dissenter was
actually the most conservative justice
the only Catholic on the court who was
troubled because we think he didn't
write an opinion but the Catholic Church
did not believe in eugenics and it was
Catholics it was nuns and priests who in
general showed up at state legislatures
and tried to defeat eugenic
sterilization laws so it is in addition
to a time that we as a country need to
think about it's a time the progressives
need to think about about you know when
when we really were on the wrong side
you mentioned and Frank go further into
the analogies and the connections to the
Nazis yeah it's also very chilling to
realize that the Nazis got their ideas
about eugenic sterilization from us we
we passed our first eugenic
sterilization law in Indiana in 1907 we
drafted the laws and there's a lot of
correspondence between Nazi scientists
and American New Genesis where they were
learning how to do what they did from us
so in in after World War two at the
Nuremberg trials when we put the the
Allies put the Nazi leadership on trial
for war crimes one of the crimes that we
prosecuted them for was eugenic
sterilization and one of the lawyers for
the Nazi defendants said how can you try
us for eugenic sterilization
and he read from buck vs. Bell and he
said you know this is your own Oliver
Wendell Holmes so he said yes we may
have done you know more than 300,000
eugenic sterilization xand the Nazis did
do more than we did but this was
something our court upheld and in the
classic movie movie judgment at
Nuremburg Maximilian Schell plays that
Nazi lawyer and in the movie he reads
from buck vs. Bell and says you know
don't you realize you know this came
from you so jumping forward to today
what are the lessons when once again in
the presidential election one major
issue is immigration whether it's
building a wall to keep out Mexicans on
the southern border or saying we don't
want Muslims in this country both of
course are
proposals by the presumptive Republican
presidential candidate Donald Trump yeah
so the eugenics story is in part about
you know the the act of other of
deciding that there are certain groups
in our midst who are inferior and
unworthy and need to be stopped and you
know in the 20s it was you know groups
that seemed a bit off the charts right
now the epileptics were considered to be
a group to be greatly feared but yeah
now we have new groups that we fear but
another lesson is you know I got into
this because I wanted to really think
about the Supreme Court and the law and
where it's gone wrong and we expect that
the Supreme Court is there to protect
the weakest in our society and and I
even at the introduction of the book I
quote from the code of hammurabi the
oldest expression of law that we that we
know of and it talks about the
importance of the law protecting the
weak from the strong that's the classic
idea of justice but American law is so
often doesn't do that you know in in in
Plessy versus Ferguson in in case after
case where we're weaker groups have gone
to the court they rule for the strong
and that's what happened here and we
have to worry now right I mean we have a
very precarious court right now four to
four anything could happen and will we
end up after the election with a court
that cares about the week and the other
or that becomes really a handmaiden to
the powerful and where does Merritt
garland what's happening with him today
the president's nominee for the Supreme
Court he seems tough a lot of time on
his hands when he should be meeting with
senators so I I wouldn't die I wouldn't
buy them any robes right now well I
think we have a few minutes open for
questions from the audience if anyone
wants to come forward to the microphone
right over here thank you Amy for coming
and thank you for this incredibly
illuminating chapter of history my name
is Jeff Spitz and I want to thank you
also for doing justice to a really
hidden story in our country's history
the story of Navajos and uranium and a
slow genocide which I applaud you for
my question has to do with point of view
in storytelling we get point of view
storytellers understand point of view
journalists are told avoid your point of
view and make a story and I'm wondering
how you balance that when you think
about let's say investigative reporting
versus what you're doing when you bring
something to light like a hidden chapter
of history young journalists are
concerned about objectivity as they get
a little older they start thinking more
perhaps but the point of view of the
story you're great I think with point of
view and have sensitivity how do you how
do you explain to people the difference
between advocacy and point of view and
objectivity or let's say the the
balanced approach you know I think this
is a great question for both of us
I mean for me I think that journalists
have an obligation to be fair and to be
accurate I mean I know so many
journalists point of view just from
watching them on television reading what
they have to say on so many different
issues and I think that's fine what
matters is fairness accuracy and also
when especially on democracy now when
people come on the broadcast whatever
their point of view that they fair feel
that they were fairly represented that
they had a chance to lay out you know
outside in an 8 or 9 second sound bite
you know I warn people when they come on
democracy now no sound bites which
shocks people but when you go to what we
have in this country sound by television
and radio you just get the establishment
consensus you know if you said like
Saddam Hussein was like Hitler you're
speaking in fort that's four seconds
you're ready for primetime and everyone
knows every reference point on what I
just said
right but if you have something else to
say
perhaps that US presidents may be guilty
of war crimes actually that just took
four seconds to but you sound a little
crazy unless you explain yourself
what are war crimes what are the
Nuremberg principles what is
international law and that you need more
time for and I really do think at this
point when you look at what we face
today
on this planet we need to be able to
broadcast the voices of people who think
outside the box who arrive at very
different conclusions and need to be
able to explain how they've come to
those points of you because I think
dissent is what will save us hi guys
thank you so much for being here
my questions about net neutrality I was
very struck a couple of weeks ago I saw
rosario Dawson on your show talking
about how that might be the next big
fight I was wondering what your thoughts
are on the issue of no
telecommunications companies trying to
sort of segment the internet and make a
profit off of that how that might that
affect people who are activist
organizers and trying to build a better
story this is a very important movement
an important question is the whole media
democracy movement challenged to keep
the internet open and free for so many
years corporations have been globalizing
the Internet is the way the grassroots
can talk to each other all over the
world and we can't let the telecoms and
the video companies the large mega
corporations privatize this global
resource that was developed as a public
resource and must remain open and free
the other question I had is about
Merrick garland seems their entrance to
me that he upheld the decision a
Citizens United decision or he upheld a
similar decision that kind of expand its
industry tonight I believe maybe a month
after the original hearing Merrick
garland I guess my question is I feel
like the media isn't really talking
about that
too much I don't know yeah I mean it's
hard to judge an appellate court judge
because very often they're bound by a
recent Supreme Court decision so when
you look at his record it's hard to know
sometimes what he had to do just because
he was applying the law and what he
wasn't but I do think most people would
agree that him being the next justice
would be so much better than a
Republican appointee so I think that's
where people can focus right now my name
is my name can I ask one quick question
Adam I just using the prerogative of as
the other person on this stage the law
on which buck vs. Bell was based what
ever happened to it well the individual
state laws are gone now but but buck vs.
Bell itself remains the law of the land
that opinion has never been overruled
the Supreme Court had an opportunity to
do it and they haven't so what's scary
is that these laws could be passed again
particularly since we have no idea where
American politics is headed right now
and also there are all kinds of new
scientific breakthroughs in this
eugenics area with things like the
editing of the human genome we're gonna
have a lot of tough choices to make we
would like to think the Supreme Court
was strongly on the record being opposed
to this kind of thing but actually it's
quite the reverse right now my name is
Gary Leavitt L EAB ITT from Skokie sorry
I was late I went to that very nice
perception and perspective discussion
with Adam Haslett and Charles Rogan my
first therapist 50 years ago or so said
I wasn't a genius and after 50 years of
therapy I believe they're generally
incompetent William Shockley you might
have mentioned he talked about IQ being
important James Flynn gave a talk in
Univision Chicago I was a member of the
public there he said he there's a flint
effect he doesn't know what his IQ is I
think it's overrated at 65 I've never
had a girlfriend but my first date my
only dates in 1992 or before was a
member of the Mensa Society Jim Fixx was
a member and he'd neglected his heart
problems and he died of a heart attack I
almost felt like I was gonna have a
heart attack from that woman genius can
be defined as two ways high IQ which is
a puzzle kind of thing that's nice but
the other is transcendent mental
superiority and when you have as I have
if you've had 50 years of therapy and
it's generally incompetent you know how
to think straight so that's yeah is
there a question
why can't a person make a sincere
statement and not live and die you can
and we appreciate what you said thank
you very much
hi two quick questions when and how did
the eugenics movement lose steam and
fade away and secondly did civil rights
organizations like the n-double a-c-p
which was founded two years after the
first eugenics law do they get involved
in opposition to eugenics early on great
question so one of the main obstacles to
the eugenics movement were the main
forces that led to its demise was the
rise of Nazi Germany and the more
eugenics became associated with the idea
of the master race and so forth the less
support there was in America so the
eugenics the main eugenics office in
America the you next record office lost
its funding which was coming from the
Carnegie Foundation because they were
worried about the association with Nazi
Germany so we saw less of it after that
and then the second time they really
lost force was in the 1960s when there
was you know a movement that began to
recognize the rights of people who were
different of incarcerated people of
mental mentally ill people and that also
so those two moments were moments of
inflection there was really a silence
from groups like civil liberties and
civil rights groups for a long time so
the ACLU was founded right around then
the American Civil Liberties Union folks
generally supported eugenics so someone
like Harry buck today there would be all
kinds of amicus groups and groups
rushing to defender there was just an
unbelievable national silence when they
gave her this terrible lawyer who didn't
want to help her no one else came to her
defense other than after the case was
inside the Catholic Church wrote a wrote
a brief but it's really again something
we progressives need to think about a
lot can I just say one last thing I want
to encourage you to read all of Adam's
books they are superb especially being
here in Chicago american pharoah
which is about Richard Daley in the
battle for Chicago and the nation as
well as the perfect store inside eBay
and also of course the latest book
imbeciles it will blow you away what it
also says about today and check out
democracynow.org if you haven't already
[Applause]
[Music]
okay well thanks to everyone for
attending this presentation mr. Cohen
and miss Goodman we'll be right outside
the auditorium signing books I know that
there are several people who've been
waiting patiently in line that want to
get in questions so if you can hold off
to the signing they'll be spending time
with everyone thank you very much if you
have any feedback or want us further
support the printers roll it fast check
us out at WWE Fastlane
[Applause]
and you're watching book TV on c-span -
you've been listening to Amy Goodman and
Adam Cohen more from Chicago in just a
few minutes
to get one